[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans cette émission
diagonale tv un spécial débutants avec
nino maso a dit maître international
monfourny mouvement jours alors
aujourd'hui dans cette leçon spécial
débutants en innu on va voir le
déplacement de deux pièces importantes
du jeu d'échecs qui sont le cavalier et
les pions oui il faut dire par avoir les
autres pieds c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué le placement des cavaliers
parce que vous allez voir qu'il se
dirige en pot bizarrement mon privé et
le pion le déplacement des pièces est
assez facile
par contre il ya les règles particulier
qui suit les pions qui sont différentes
en pot or de comment on va voir le coup
notamment le prix et les promotions
mais ne vous inquiétez pas les échecs
restera accessible à tout le monde bien
sûr c'est quand même c'est pas si
compliqué que ça alors on va voir tout
de suite le déplacement de ce fameux
bourrin le kava l'os lecavalier le
cheval le
le gua la plaine nom différent alors
c'est une pièce tout à fait
extraordinaire le cheval alors ici on a
mis deux deux cavaliers on va voir
comment ces cavaliers bouge alors
comment on peut expliquer le déplacement
du cac magnanime
donc c'est pour les enfants un peu aux
normands difficile c'est vos enfants
regard des missions et selon explique
pour faciliter les choses c'est comme
grande et parfois on dit comme ça mais
voilà que parfois on est clair comme ça
mais c'est pas forcément d'être bien
expliqué déjà pour donc montrons où ça
peut aller sept cavaliers donc alors ce
cas elle est poli sur cette case celle
ci celle ci celle ci celle ci celle ci
celle ci est celle ci alors pourquoi ont
elles ce qu'on voit bien ici regardez la
forme de l ici un petit elle ici voilà
mais c'est un peu trompeur de parler de
l parce que le cavaly saute par dessus
des pièces oui donc parfois vous pouvez
croire
si vous n'avez pas été signé entre
guillemets et ça marche pas non
finalement il faut quand même retenir
les cases final de destination
voilà mais si vous voulez pour pas
placer le cavalier n'importe où et vous
rappelle et c'est à peu près là bas en
trois cases donc pensé à elle peut être
fait fort lors il ya une autre façon de
le dire lors chacun a son truc moi j'ai
trouvé une façon
intéressante de le signaler le cavaly va
toujours sur la case de couleur opposée
à sa case de départ est à 2 càs de
distance regardez c'est le meilleure
façon de retenir
voilà il ya deux quasi site distant et
alors on va sur toutes les cases
blanches puisqu'il est sur les cases
noires toutes les cases blanches qui
sont à 2 càs de distance inversement
inversement le cavalier sur le plan il
est sur une case blanche ici il va aller
donc sur les cases p 6 et c'est cette
rade et c'est bien à deux cases et en
sautant par dessus alors a noté howard
et que celui ci il peut aller sur huit
cases à la fois alors que celui là comme
il est au bord b évidemment ya pas il
manque des classes sur les côtés oui
pourrait aller mieux n'a pas donc il
peut aller qu'il a beaucoup moins de gaz
à sa disposition déjà on vous rappelle
on n'est pas au niveau stratégique que
cette fois on juge d'apprendre déplacer
les pièces mais sachez qu'il est
vraiment très bien toujours placer
l'école et dans le centre parce que
comme stéphane viens de vous dire car
les quais au coin dulac d'occase donc il
est très limité alors qu'à l'est dans le
centre et l'a8 casse mais c'est vraiment
gênant pour toutes les pièces
oui mais surtout cavaliers surtout
carrément placez le dans le centre voilà
et que les quatre centrales d'ailleurs
au rappel ça s'appelle les quatre cas ce
qu'ils sont oubliés perd et on peut
montrer parce que oui alors les gars
central cc 4 cases la voilà voilà on
démontre aussi en jouant ici ça c'est
donc ce carré qui sur une case centrale
il est beaucoup dire et sans voilà voilà
donc on voit les choses on va régler un
pl oui par exemple
maintenant si vous arrivez à distinguer
comment ça marche déjà comment le
cavalier peut capturer le travail est
par exemple parce que dans les autres
cours que vous avez vraiment au conseil
voire nous coûte précédent pour
comprendre entièrement le jeu on va vous
expliquer les captures comment ça marche
et donc par exemple ici comment on peut
capturer le cavalier noir stéphanie
alors comment on peut que nous mettons
qu'on se déplacer que les noirs ne
déplace que le roi 1 que ce soit que les
blancs qui joue donc on s'en serait ici
sur cette case là ou sur celle là ce ne
peut paraît d'ailleurs alors celle là
ici donc les noirs par exemple ne
toucherez pas leurs cavaliers pour
comment te faut que les noirs jouent
quand même un coût dont qu'il jouerait
le roi ici on déplace le cavalier
ensuite sur cette case là à regarder on
n'est plus qu'à une seule case à faire
un seul saut ducal du cavaliere
donc si les noirs jouer encore le roi
ici il suffirait de prendre maintenant
le cavalier adverse voilà donc en alors
un autre une un autre chemin possible
donc là on a fait 1 2 3 et ce sera
toujours 3 mais on va trouver un autre
chemin
ces deux plats c'est par ici et noir
jour et le roi pareil on viendrait sur
cette case menouar aujourd hui le roi et
on prendrait donc à macao juste rappel
qu'ait aux échecs c'est actuaires joue à
son tour
donc c'est pour ça on dit parfois chaque
fois qu'ils ont déplacé une pièce
maintenant c'est à l'adversaire est de
placer ses pièces donc elia chacun de sa
tour voilà donc en fait si ça se passait
vraiment dans une partie en fait on peut
faire des coups
cavalier là on joue le roi s'il est
blanc mettaient leurs cavaliers ici les
noirs maintenant en train de jouer pour
eux-mêmes prendre le cavalier donc ça
serait pas une bonne idée un bref
attention on vous juste estime pour
l'instant les les possibilités mais
voilà on englobe aussi bilité mais c'est
pas forcément ce qu'il faut c'est pas
forcément les bons coups mais c'est pour
voir comment on bouge comme en bouche le
cavalier comment on aurait pu
effectivement prendre la pièce ats en
vous pourrez jamais faire du coup la
suite aux échecs c'est pour ça qu'une
fois arrivé donc sur ces 7
c'est l'adversaire aussi voilà alors on
va montrer aussi que les lecavalier en
fait non
ossements c'est pas comme la tour le fou
la dame qui qui sont bloqués dans leur
progression
s'il ya une pièce de leur propre camp
ailleurs ou du camp adverse 6 et du camp
adverse ils peuvent la prendre mais ils
peuvent pas aller au delà
par contre ici on va montrer un exemple
il suffit que si les blancs jouent ici
par exemple et que les noirs jouent
leurs cavaliers sur la case b6
lecavalier là peut toujours venir sur
les cases à cette ou ces sept le cal est
là ne fait pas obstacle le calice 5 par
dessus même s'il y avait d'autres pièces
ici sur ces cases la des pièces des
pions n'importe quoi le gall et pourrait
toujours revenir sur ces six vous
rappelez des positions de départ des
deux courants numéro un a révisé donc là
vous vous allez voir le kawaï et peut
tout de suite sauté sur les pions tout à
fait dans la position initiale
le cavalier les cavaliers ont regardé
fait un petit effort d'imagination les
cavaliers sont placés ici et même il ya
des pions évidemment sur ses rangées là
partout tout à fait ici et donc les
cavaliers peuvent directement
on n'est pas obligé de jouer les pions
au début on peut très bien revenir sur
la case f3c 3 sur la case à 3 ou alors
pour l'autre cavalier peut très bien
aller sur la case f3 voix est là car
rien sur ce sera la même chose pour les
noirs et c'est pareil pour les noirs
évidemment donc on va placer maintenant
on va passer par don maintenant
justement en déplacement des pions qui
vont nous intéresser et qui est encore
plus techniques les pions le petit pion
il est bourré de ressources en fait on
va voir ça alors ici voilà on a en a mis
deux pions alors donc hautement se
déplace le pion voilà au début rien de
particulier puisque les pions 7e place
tout droit et c'est très facile à jouer
c'est le seul ps aux échecs il n'a pas
droit de réguler n'est pas oublier ça
parce que n'importe quelle pièce jouée
vous allez voir après roy aussi une
importe la tour le fou qu'on a déjà
passé la dame il peut réunir cannes eu
lieu mais pas les pions une fois tout
fait il revient jamais donc voilà donc
le pion va tout droit donc en principe
le pion va pas une seule case en
principe donc voilà en par an mais
l'entrée on va montrer voilà par exemple
vous bouger comme ça les noirs etc
vous allez comprendre le pied on ne peut
pas aller donc ni sur les rangées ni sur
les diagonales pour enfants
juste droits que tout ne l'a pas trop le
choix les lions n'ont pas le choix
d'aller autrement que tout droit voyez
donc c'est très facile quand vous voyez
maintenant donc les petites
complications entre guillemets première
exception c'est pas exception d une
règle première donc notice sait qu'il
peut aller sur d'occase
exceptionnellement à la départ donc donc
le pion où il peut au départ sert quand
il est encore sur sa case nos départs
sur la deuxième rangée pour les blancs
et la septième pour les noirs n'importe
quand dans la partie c'est pas que le
premier coup la partie si le premier
coup du pion concernés même si vous dire
est plus rien comme case là c'est le cas
d'ailleurs si on peut imaginer que ça
c'est une fin de partie alors c'est une
scène partie les blancs peuvent jouer
leurs pions soit d'une case évidemment
ça c'est le coût normal
où est alors au joueur le choix ils ont
le choix de jouer de deux cases
c'est le seul cas le seul moment c'est
encore le pion est encore sur la
première case il a le choix entre une ou
deux cadres
c'est le seul cas après il n'a plus le
choix que de se déplacer que 2 par
exemple et noir jouent lui de une case
et après on peut se déplacer que d'une
case on n'a plus le choix
y a plus cette possibilité donc cette
pièce des cats ne veut pas venir sont
des deux par exemple ils disent il si
par exemple vous ne pouvez pas plus
venir par exemple sur directement sur
des docks on va venir ici sur des deux
parce qu'on n'est pas sur la fois les
remparts ont donc alors que au débat
dont convient d'expliquer vous pouvez
aller parfois en fait si vous avez un
lui sur ducasse voilà donc au départ on
a le choix entre une case ou deux au
départ du pion quand le pion est encore
sur sa case initiale il a le choix
donc classer le joueur quel choix
maintenant au passé sur le prix c'est
qui est aussi une règle exceptionnel
alors on va voir maintenant prise du
pion alors le pion se déplace comme ça
mais comment il prend alors si si on
suivait la règle qu'on a vu pour toutes
les pièces
il devrait prendre comme il avance c'est
à dire juste devant lui oui et c'est le
seul ps donc déjà qu'on a dit que c'est
le ps qui ne revient pas en arrière
maintenant celle que celle pièce unique
c'est très différent des autres pièces
qui ne prend pas habituellement
vous allez voir alors on nous a expliqué
il se dirige devant mais il prend sur
les diagonales à côté alors ça c'est
vraiment c'est à dire fou si on prend le
cas de ce pion ici ni non
oui il a le choix il peut venir
évidemment une case ici ou deux quasi si
c'est ça quand vous avez appris une case
ou d'occasion pareil s'est déplacé tout
simplement jouer ce coup là on va jouer
un coup le roi et jouer ce coup là où
aller recta main directement jouer
directement de deux cases ici donc ça
c'est ce qu'on vient de voir
oui et on le met par contre il y peut
pas prendre le devant d'ailleurs et
jae-bum mais par exemple on achète on a
montré cet exemple si on fume je sais
qu'on peut pas prendre le taureau par
exemple et blanc jouent le coup de trois
mines se dit pas super mon pions ici h7
je vais bouger d'une quasi je vais
prendre la tour parce que tout à l'heure
on a vu que tous les pièces sur les
routes et croisés il pourrait pas de
capturer ces pièces adversaire signe en
fait non mais là nous on veut pas il est
bloqué il est bloqué il est plongé la
pas le droit de prendre la tour alors
moment les pions prennent lippi ont donc
froid sur les diagonales à les pions
prennent sur les diagonales donc voilà
option ils vont prendre donc les pions
ici peut prendre mais sur une case
initiale casse n'imaginais pas que vous
allez kung fu pour prendre quelque chose
où on peut aller que d'une seule classe
donc on peut bien soit le plus bref 3
soit s'ils avaient une pièce ici mis en
a pas si vous avez une ps juste à côté
voilà on peut prendre l'adversaire
attention parce sa propre au ps on a dit
qu'on ne capture pas ses propres pièces
donc que vous pouvez prendre là par
exemple
autre exemple quand on reprend 2,3 et
voilà voilà
on apprend qu'on a retiré cette pièce
d'une l'échiquier on a pris sa place
comme tout à l'heure pour les autres
pièces donc ce sera la même chose donc
imaginé pour ces cinq donc sept pions
comme un élu à prendre il apprend aussi
donc vous soit vous prenez à gauche ou à
droite c'est peu importe il suffit que
vous avez une pièce in pieces sur la
petite diagonale juste à côté du pion
voilà mais par contre là ici ce pion ici
ne peut pas prendre la tour puisque la
tour et juste devant foca est la tour
c'est par exemple si les tours je joue
mais d'insurgés 6 si l'aca russie ce qui
serait une faute
là il peut prendre voilà alors il ya le
choix le pion on n'est pas obligé de
prendre aux échecs évidemment oui on
n'est pas obligé à prendre et et on sent
bien pu bouger en âge cette page 6
pardon ou alors en scène qu on aurait
très bien pu jouer ce coup évidemment on
faire l'occurrence si on nous offre une
tour gratuite
on va peut-être la prendre
voilà donc ça on a vu l'a donc là c'est
pas pareil
petit rappel une fois cette paix en
surgissent ici lé peuple ou aller sur
d'occase par exemple parce qu'il est
déjà bougé déjà bien on voit pas les
surcoûts g4 on recollerait mais si on
referait 5g quatre ans par an on ne peut
pas venir ici il y avait aussi
directement noms dont quelques beaucoup
pour arriver jusqu'ici
voilà donc il faut venir ici après on
pourra bouger on n'a rien apprendre ici
à rien apprendre ici non plus donc la 6e
joueuse 4 par contre il on s'est croisés
si on joue f4 si des noirs maintenant
joue le coup g5 et bien on peut prendre
voilà ou alors on peut avancer on n'est
pas obligé de prendre on peut choisir et
notamment prendre le pion fils inc on
espère vous avez compris ça on va passer
à la promotion alors qu'est ce que c'est
que ça la promotion donc on n'a jamais
rien à vue alors le pion c'est quand
même compliqué parce qu'alors dont le
cavalier déjà c'est pas simple puisque
on a vu qu'il a un déplacement bon on a
compris et xavier de cases plus loin il
saute par dessus et il atterrit sur une
case de couleurs opposées
bon le pion on a vu que le pion 1 quand
il ya encore sur sa première case il
peut choisir de bouger devant lui d'une
ou de deux cases
s'il a une pièce devant lui il est
coincé quand il prend il prend sur sa
diagonale
alors non seulement déjà c'est compliqué
mais alors en plus maintenant il ya une
nouveauté alors tout à fait
extraordinaire avec le pion ces
parisiens passante déjà c'est la
présence pas leur oui c'est à dire il ya
deux prises il ya deux nouveautés
extraordinaire qu'on va voir ici il ya
un la prise en passant alors qui est
quelque chose de tout à fait fantastique
oui vous allez voir c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel mentionne encore plus
exceptionnel et la promotion
voilà donc l'option c'est peut-être une
pièce qui va pas loin qui est un peu
mais d'abord ainsi une pièce qui est en
sus un surnom puisqu'il y en a 8 sur les
signer mon coup plus que les autres
pièces et en plus vous avez vu toutes
les règles qui sont sur le pion pour
cette petite pièce qui ont fait quelque
chose de tout à fait magique alors ici
dans cette position on va voir par
exemple simple passade donc alors si
c'est aux blancs de jouer imaginons que
les blancs jouent le coup c4 alors on
peut jouer ce coup puisque le pion était
encore sur la première case on a le
choix ici entre jouer le pion sur ces
trois sur ces 3 ou sur ces 4 on n'a pas
d'autre choix puisqu'il n'y a pas de
pièces en b3 ya pas de pièces en d3 donc
on n'a rien à apprendre
donc si on joue ces 4 si on joue alors
déjà on va le dire si on joue le
ou c3 évidemment les tellines est donc
ici voilà au choix aux alternatifs noir
dont peuvent jouer ça par exemple le
coup ici soit le couple évident pour
jouer le pion aux tirs mais en
l'occurrence ici on peut choisir de
prendre le pion bon donc les blancs se
disent super bon j'ai vu qu'il peut me
prendre
si je joue le pion en c3 donc afin
d'échapper à cette prise je vais jouer
mon pion de deux cases mais là et là une
oreille crise alors ça s'appelle la
prise en bassin et c'est extraordinaire
et donc on vous traite tout de suite
qu'est ce que ça veut dire youpi on paie
comme capturer ses pions blancs qui a
loire le droit des captures et l'eau
pure noir peut prendre regarder dans le
vide il il comme si le pion n'avait
bougé que d'une case voyez c'est pour ça
que je vous montrer que si on joue ces
trois et noir peuvent prendre et et si
on joue ses cartes est belle et douce à
la mémoire autant quand même regarder
ils prennent en passant regarder le
petit ont disparu regardez comme c'est
énorme on joue l'option de 2,15 et le
noie le tournoi reprend dans le vide et
fait disparaître le pur alors justement
va expliquer quand même cette règle qui
est quand même extraordinaire
justement au départ historiquement les
pions ne pouvait pas jouer de deux cases
mais on voyait que les parties étaient
un peu lente et c'est donc pour
accélérer le jeu on a dit bon au premier
coup d'un pion il peut jouer et de
quatre oui mais alors y'a des joueurs
après qui ont fait leur marque oui mais
attendez parce qu'avant quand j'avais un
pion ici jean péché manquions d'avancé
et maintenant avec votre nouvelle règle
je peux plus et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a inventé la règle en passant si alors
la règle est la suivante elle faut être
précis quand même si le pion adverse
joue de deux cases et qu'on a un pion
donc placé ici soit à droite soit à
gauche sur la case ici et b4 ou des cats
est vrai évidemment pour tous les pions
et bien le coup d'après uniquement le
coup d'après uniquement c'est pas
valable un coup de coude trois coups
plus tard le coup d'après uniquement
uniquement dans le cas où le pion
adverse a bougé de deux cases
oui le coup d'après uniquement le pion
peut prendre le pion adverse ici comme
s'ils avaient bougé que d'une seule case
c'est ça la règle en fait vous pourrez
marquer très facilement quand même pour
faire prise en passant si vous êtes avec
le noir il faut absolument être comme
vous ou votre pion soit sur quatrième
rangée parce que c'est le sel en dhr
4e rangée où l'adversaire ou à bouger
sont bien sûr d'occase parce que
peut-être case départ tk ce départ comme
l'endroit où le pion la 3d bouger sur
dos cassé le case de départ c'est-à-dire
deuxième rangée
donc ça va me passer si le puits on
était sur une autre place 4e rangée
quand vous en montrer quatrième rangée
donc c'est pas très malin en flèche et
vous voilà ça c'est catherine granger
par contre avec les blancs cet exemple
peut être uniquement dans les cas si
vous êtes sûr cinquième round j'ai parce
qu'elle les pièces adversaires il doit
se déplacer suscinio déplacer sur daugas
des pièces d'été case de départ
voilà donc on va revoir on va revoir
l'astuce imaginons que les blancs jouent
de deux cases alors on a le choix on
n'est pas obligé de prendre donc
imaginons que ce soit les noirs aux
mêmes qui jouent leurs pions
ce pion angers7 toujours ce recasement
et paris le joug de deux cases et bien
les blancs peuvent choisir d'abord de
jouer le roi de jouer ce pont là mais
aussi répondre de pousser le pion ou
alors de prendre en passant donc la
prise en passant ont regardé c'est
fantastique
hop je prends comme si le pouls du noir
n'avait bougé que d'une case uniquement
le coup d'après si vous jouez à notre
cou vous n'avez plus le droit de faire
cette prise évidemment c'est que le coup
d'après vous avez ce choix hop et le
pion disparaissent et c'est que oui on
va donc rappeler répéter donc il faut
prendre tout de suite si vous avez une
prendre après ozap le droit là par
exemple qui reçurent des 4 s'il ne prend
pas tout de suite ou sur g5 n'importe
quel que là par exemple si les noirs ne
prend pas sur ces trois tout de suite
après c'est fini là ils n'auront plus
droit de toucher moncton high peaks donc
donc sur montre ici donc c'est quatre
temps entre cinq et on appelle ça le
pion f prend la case justice et le pion
ici aussi remarqué ça veut passer avec
n'importe quel point comme sur n'importe
quel colonnes et soit à gauche ou à
droite
alors maintenant on sait qu'on va voir
c'est que et bien ses pions sont tout
proches ou professions faire la
promotion alors imaginons que les deux
noirs maintenant joue le coup par
exemple droit ici on pousse le pion ici
donc on explique que c'est quoi la
promotion donc
ce que c'est la promo promotion c'est
quelque chose de magique il peut dire et
là on regarde et attire voilà donc c'est
l'heure l'option ici est proche de
fernand oui qu'est ce qui se passe quand
on arrive au dernier rang j'ai donc si
vous avez les blancs vous arrive au 8e
rang j'ai donc et avec le noir par
exemple au premier rang j'ai alors
regardé ce que propose mon petit
logiciel ici quand je suis arrivé au
bout ici il me dit qu'est ce que je veux
une dame ou une tour ou un fou ou un
cavalier pas forcément une dame d'un
général fait dans notre petit pion ou à
se transformer par avoir votre choix
dans une pièce plus puissante qu'il
était avant donc c'est une sorte de
récompense pour avoir le courage arrive
jusqu'à dernier à angers
alors on a le choix on n'est pas obligé
de faire la main c'est à dire que ici je
peux très bien choisir de faire cavalier
ça peut arriver à des cas particuliers
on va préférer faire un cavalier pour
pour des raisons techniques
on va vous dire non à peu près 99% je
pense qu'on va faire plus tôt la dame
parce que c'est une pièce très
puissantes comme on a vu c'est la
combinaison de tours et faux dans un
autre autre courbe est aussi dans un cas
particulier comme souvent on vient de
dire donc on peut choisir soit le fou
soit le cavalier soit la tour attention
on peut pas dire moi je ne veux rien
déjà mon ce sera bizarre tu as refusé
cette possibilité de d'avoir fait son
pied une pièce puissante mais vous
pouvez pas juste laissé un pion sarthe
un enfant peut penser aux militants
voilà ce qui selon vous pouvez jamais
faire roues abs que dans un âge où il
n'existait pas avoir droit
alors que vous pouvez revoir donc
finalement on voir dauda entrée 3
d'armes quatre cavaliers si vous faites
quatre promotions ou pour faire tant que
vous voulez si vous arrivez c'est à dire
les ranger on a huit pions on a deux
cavaliers déjà au départ donc si on peut
faire éventuellement on peut trouver une
partie où on peut faire en tout on
pourrait avoir dix cavaliers
oui c'est au fait si on arrivait passé
oui si on arrivait de ramasser donc
capturer tous les pions d'adversaire
pour libérer les cascades surtout après
faire huit fois promotion
ça sera très fort mais ça n'existait pas
ou ne rêve pas loupé le drop dans la
pratique
dans la pratique on peut faire voir
jusqu à d'autres options mais pas plus
que ça oui en général que les pille on
s'échange aussi au début aussi voilà
alors on va voir un autre exemple ici
non non je crois qu'il y avait un autre
je vais juste passer rapidement
voilà ici
si oui ou non ce que je voulais montrer
c'est que si les blancs jouent ici
oui et non je crois qu'il y avait
quelque chose à montrer c'est que si
quand on arrive au bout une ancienne
pièce on n'a pas le cas ici mais si on a
une pièce ici évidemment on peut choisir
de faire dame en prenant la pièce ou
alors en avançant que ça ne vous
interdit pas de faire promotion soit pas
reprise doivent avancer quand vous avez
expliqué il veut prendre la main sur
l'imaginaire une tour ici adverse et
bien évidemment on pourrait la prendre
en même temps et ça ferait quand même
promotion on pourrait changer
donc ça vous empêche pas par contre s'il
ya une pièce donc justement placé on
indiqué ça va bloquer voilà et bien donc
arrêtée mais avec les pions comme c'est
une pièce exceptionnelle donc qui ne
prend pas sur sa route
normand pour arrêter l'agression des
pions s'ils nous attaquent
il suffit de placer quelque chose une
pièce t27 pions et ça va s'arrêter
il faut pas placer par contre juste à
côté sur le diagonal pour qui le projet
avance bien sûr donc ce pion est tout à
fait extraordinaire il peut bouger donc
de deux cases au début ou lors d'une
case de façon générale devant lui il
prend sur les côtés il peut être pris en
passant quand ils jouent sont deux cas
et s'il ya un pion adverse sur la
quatrième rangée pour les blancs sur la
5eme ranger pour les noirs et donc quand
ils arrivent au bout il se transforme en
plus à une pièce
qui peut être beaucoup plus puissants
dont les pions sont très très importants
aux échecs et il peut paraît que les
arrêts délire là par exemple comme sur
kiev 7 il peut jamais faire on a alors
interdit de recul et ainsi on a oublié
de dire on finance et ubs qui n'a pas
droit de réguler c'est la seule pièce
c'est la seule pièce toutes les autres
pièces le peut la seule pièce qui
effectivement ne peut pas reculer aux
échecs le pion voilà donc vous avez vu
les deux pièces peut-être les plus
difficiles à cerner aux échecs qui sont
le pion et les pions et les cavaliers
qui sont sans doute effectivement les
pièges de plus difficile à appréhender
beaucoup plus que tour fouet dame qui
qu'ils soient relativement simple à
comprendre mais le prochain coup vous
aider d'assimiler les rares mouvements
et vous allez voir ça va aller plus
facilement
voilà donc c'est terminé pour cette
leçon sur les cavaliers et les pions
voilà il vous dit à bientôt pour une
autre émission merci d'inonder rien
horreur
[Musique]